Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to
Nicole from Utah? Nicole from Utah.
Welcome to the program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: Hi, David. Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Okay. I want your thoughts on just how
many people are entering the Republican
primary race and how they are all saying the
same things about former President Trump.
Speaker 1: And they're not really saying much.
Right. I mean, is that sort of part of your point?
Yes. Yeah. I think that there are a
couple of different things going on.
It's not a crazy idea to think to yourself.
Trump's been arrested once. He may get arrested
again. He may get arrested a third time at
least. And that's just by this September.
He may legitimately struggle to stay in this
race because he will be so tied up in court.
And so I want to be there as an alternative.
If indeed, Trump, who has a commanding lead,
is unable to run in a way that makes sense. The
problem is and so part of this is if I want to
be there to pick up Trump's supporters, I
can't be the one Republican who's running
who is going to do the biggest criticisms of
Trump. So this is why Tim Scott and Nikki Haley
and whoever else will talk about it, time for a
change or a different generation or whatever. But
they won't really go after him. The unfortunate
reality for them is that if you're polling one,
two, three, four or five and DeSantis is at 20
something, if indeed Trump has that issue that
pushes him out of the race, a lot of that support
will almost certainly go to DeSantis, who is the
most viable in the context of the general election
and also already has the most support and is using
the exact same strategy so far. Yes, DeSantis has
sort of gone after Trump a little bit, but he said
he would pardon him and he's talking more about
Joe Biden than he is about Trump. So I think it's
a deliberate strategy from all of them saying,
listen, let me let me be around in case Trump
collapses. But they're not generating any path
to the nomination for themselves. They're sort
of waiting around for one to be handed to them. I
don't think it's going to work. I agree with you.
All right, Nicole from Utah, thank you.
Speaker 3: Thanks for having.
Speaker 1: Me. All right. There goes Nicole.
Let's go next to Ty from Iowa. Ty from Iowa.
Speaker 3: Hello? David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: Okay, so I just wanted to bring this up
because there's just something I kind of noticed
that and I feel like it's it's usually with
either figures that are passed away by people
that have passed away or it's like a famous movie
or something like that or a book. But I've I've
noticed a bunch of people. So, for instance, you
know how George Orwell is someone that that people
on the right seem to really, really love. I.
Speaker 1: I guess. I mean, do they. They. They
really just talk about things being Orwellian
in the sense of 1984. Big Brother, government
surveillance, government overreach. But I don't
know that they love Orwell. Many of them don't
even really know what Orwell wrote, to be honest.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I know, But I just. I mean,
I guess I just kind of like I just remember seeing
someone on their Twitter bio that was like a Trump
page, and it said Orwell was right. Oh, yeah.
Speaker 1: Well, no. I mean, I think what
we can say is they like referencing things
being Orwellian, even if they don't really
understand them that I would agree with.
Speaker 3: Yeah, but it's just weird because
Orwell was a socialist. Yes, he was an anti
fascist and all this other stuff. He wouldn't
be like if they if they think Biden's a socialist,
they would think they would.
They would just like, blush if
they saw someone like Orwell as president.
Speaker 1: No, that's absolutely true. And I
think that comes through much more in Animal
Farm, which is another Orwell book more than
it does in 1984, the sort of sort of socialist
ideas. I mean, listen, you have to understand,
this right wing movement is a movement that has
been anti-intellectual, pseudo intellectual,
skeptical of or even hostile to deep thinking and
higher education for a long time now. And so the
fact that they even mentioned Orwell is sort of
remarkable, but they know very, very little. If
you say, hey, you know, can you kind of compare
and contrast Orwell's vision in 84 versus Aldous
Huxley's vision in Brave New World? And which do
you think applies more? These aren't folks who are
able to engage in on that. They've just they heard
Orwellian and now they've started using the term.
But I don't really think these are serious people.
Speaker 3: Yeah. And then like another one is the
Matrix is another one. So I got the red pill
and all this other stuff and there's even a
going on thing for Follow the White
Rabbit. And the people that made the
The Matrix are two transgender sisters. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I know the identity thing is
funny, but listen, they don't care. It's just
like. Like I said, I wouldn't read that much
into it because these truly aren't serious
people. We need to get around them to make
progress. That's the unfortunate reality.
Speaker 3: Yeah, that makes sense.
Speaker 1: All right, Ty from
Iowa, thank you for the call.
Speaker 3: Thank you for taking my call.
Speaker 1: All right, there goes Ty.